so after these surgeries
mm-hmm is that all that you're gonna
want are you gonna wanna do anything
else to yourself
yes i gotta do liposuction because i
cannot lost this fat in here
and i'm going to do liposuction in my
thighs
in my belly are you going to get needy
might move me
so the breasts so you feel at your best
the nose mm-hmm lippo
yeah lipo to take it off this fatty hair
that it cut out lost anymore
and the thighs and the butt
what do you mean the butt hold on put
the fat let them take it off the belly
in the butt
so it never ends head to toe when i look
like your hair i always stop
this one the surgery i want to have this
belly
and this leg
you're gonna look like a mannequin yeah
larissa has told me
hey this is the last time i'm doing this
or the last time i'm doing that
and she's always just continued to
surprise me with hey this is what i want
next
and i don't know if it's ever gonna stop
or not
you know if it makes her feel happy and
confident about herself that's cool
but if the wrist is unhappy that kind of
puts me on edge and it
kind of irks me a little bit to hey how
do we make you happy
this gentleman's gonna pay for three
fans okay
this sweetheart man
larissa before the baby job is larissa
that was insecure
very difficult arrested many times
finally
after two years i'm gonna get my boobs
done
so i feel very happy that i'm gonna wake
up and everything gonna change